my name is C and Laurie I'm a professor
at the Scripps Research Institute and I
study stem cells where LAN tell you
today is a set of tools that we've
developed to try to make stem cell
therapies as safe as possible let me
show you my first slide shows what my
labs vision is we plan to use genomic
tools to drive discovery and translation
of pluripotent stem cell based therapies
and that Venn diagram you see is our
overlap between pluripotent stem cells
represented by that tree and genomics
the first on that list in the overlap is
autologous cell therapy for Parkinson's
disease and that's why I'm going to
focus on today because this is a therapy
that we plan to take the clinic
relatively soon and so a lot of our
effort has been focused on developing
tools to make sure that the therapy is
safe and effective but we are also
working on drug development using a
multiple sclerosis model and we're
trying to understand the basis of
fragile X and autism by using IPS cells
from people with fragile X syndrome and
with the San Diego Zoo I am studying
method through using IPS cells to
generate gametes so that we can try to
rescue the northern white rhino which is
a species that is going to be extinct in
our lifetime
so you probably already know but I'll
remind you that the sources of
pluripotent stem cells are embryonic
stem cells which were first made from
humans in 1998 that is a picture of an
or drawing of an embryo the cells that
are shown by the air of the inner cell
mass cells are placed into culture and
expanded and they give rise to human
embryonic stem cells in 2007 Shinya
Yamanaka developed a method for making
the same cell type but making it from
individuals from their skin and that can
also be made from other cell types in a
human body which means that we can make
personalized induced pluripotent stem
cells very potent stem cells from every
individual that involves in our lab in
making dermal fire floss first and then
using Yamanaka reprogramming factors to
turn the cells into pluripotent stem
cells and this is my diagram again of
showing the tree to represent all the
things that were taught the stem cells
can give rise to in the body and up in
the upper right hand corner you'll see
that when those cell types is definitely
neurons the reason it seems that
dopamine neurons are important is
because they're involved in a
regenerative therapy for Parkinson's
disease that we've been developing for
about the last six years the Parkinson's
disease is caused by the loss of a
particular type of neuron in the brain a
dopamine neuron in a particular part of
the brain which is the substantial [ __ ]
this little tiny bit of the brain makes
all the dopamine neurons that project
the send axons into the striatum which
is the one of the nodes in this network
that leads to control over five
movements I'm sure you know that the
symptoms of Parkinson's disease are our
loss of fine motor control which is
manifest either by tremors or by a
freezing and being unable to move or
both
alternatively there are a lot of people
with Parkinson's disease it's the second
most common neurological disorder 50,000
or more Americans are diagnosed
diagnosed every year and they aren't
diagnosed until half of their government
or neurons are already gone it is a
progressive degeneration of these cells
and so by the time they're diagnosed
they're already halfway through their
supply of dopamine neurons and they will
continue to die because the drug therapy
which is l-dopa
does not stop the loss of neurons the
drug therapy has been around since the
1960s
l-dopa revs up the remaining dopamine
neurons so that they can function better
but it doesn't stop their loss so
currently there's no disease modifying
treatment at all so we propose that
doesn't mean neuron replacement is may
be able to give the patient's decades
long therapeutic benefit now this is
just a slide this is a figure from a
paper that was published last year by
Roger Barker and colleagues about the
four groups who are sharing plans
through our stem cell derived dopamine
neuron replacement for Parkinson's
disease I'll just you don't need to read
all the stuff on there but the important
things are that Roger Barker and Malin
Palmer who are in the UK and Sweden are
using human embryonic stem cells and
since they will not match the patient
they will need to use immunosuppression
for at least one year Laurens tutor in
New York is also using human embryonic
stem cells and will require
immunosuppression during Takahashi who's
in Japan is using a single induced
pluripotent stem cell line but it won't
be a perfect match for the patients and
so he will also be using
immunosuppression
and lastly my group here in La Jolla is
using a targis IPS cells that is
patient-specific
IPS cells we're making the cells from
each patient so we can avoid
immunosuppression
this group is called g-force PD and it
meets every year or so to coordinate
their efforts to take these these
therapies to the clinic
an overview of our very simple approach
the upper left-hand corner shows the
cover of stem cells and development and
it is that Journal has in it that the
paper which is cited at the bottom which
is an overview I wrote of an rationale
for why we use an autologous or a potent
stem cells we call this a neuron
replacement not a stem cell replacement
it's important because that
differentiates us from all the clinics
that are working without FDA approval
using stem cells as they get from
people's own bodies
so there's the brain again on the side
and then on the right hand side just
shows the steps we make induced
pluripotent stem cells from each patient
we use those IPS cells to generate
dopamine neurons and then we transplant
them back to the patient the site of the
transplantation will be the striatum
which is the place where the dopamine
neurons in the substantia [ __ ] makes
their synapses
pathologist neuron replacement was that
it had certain advantages chief among
those is that no immune suppression is
needed this will decrease the problems
that the patients have from infections
that are caused by the immunosuppression
or that are allowed to develop because
the immunosuppression and it also
because of that will lead to lower care
costs for the patients after they
receive a transplant also there is no
scale-up required we only need two to
five million neurons for each transplant
that means that unlike Carty therapies
or other therapies that are meant to
replace certain cell types like cardiac
cells for example we don't need to make
a billion cells that will make our
manufacturing costs lower and it also
makes it easier for us to do quality
control and importantly no rejection
will happen if we have to reduce the
patient's so we don't know exactly how
many neurons are going to be required we
plan to transplant a sufficient neurons
so that they will alleviate these
symptoms of Parkinson's disease but if
we discover in our phase one trials that
people are not fully recovering we can
in fact we react dopamine neurons
because they will not be rejected their
self not non-self and also since we Bank
the IPS cells from each patient in
theory those same cells could be used to
make other cell types for other cell
therapies in the future there are
however some challenges we need to get
the IPS cells made from every patient we
need reproducible methods for dopamine
neuron differentiation in other words we
need methods that work for every cell
line not for a single cell line if we
needed to use quality control using
animal studies it would be too expensive
so we need to have quality control
methods that can be substituted for each
cell line being studies animals and
importantly we will need to look at
multiple cell lines all of the cell
lines to find out whether they have
potentially dangerous mutations
this next slide is a an overview of our
quality control which is what we've
mostly been working on
besides our differentiation method we've
developed now this is where the genomics
comes in I have three across the top is
the message from IPS cells to an
intermediate stage we're telling the
cells now that they're going to be
neurons and that they need to be a
particular type of neuron that is in the
bottom of the early embryos floor plate
the bottom of the neural tube and then
we tell the neurons that they're
supposed to make the exact type of
definitely neuron which is made in which
eventually will give rise to this
obsession a gret during field
development this is
takes 25 days 18 to 25 days and this is
a stage at which we plan to do the
transplantation at this stage the
neurons have little tiny processes
they're not mature and so we get pretty
good and get very good survival of the
cells they're not all dopamine neurons
yet but they're also no longer dividing
so it's a sweet spot in this
differentiation scheme to get the
maximum surviving neurons for transplant
but we do keep the cells longer because
we want to make sure that the cells that
we have when those culture dishes are
capable of making maturer dopamine
neurons so you'll see those little
triangles underneath the blue is
conventional quality control which is
used as markers like of minnesota
chemistry which is actually shown in
that upper path
flow cytometry and rt-pcr and this is to
make sure that the cells pass the
criteria to take them forward whether
it's taking them forward through the
differentiation scheme or taking them
forward to transplant to patients the
orange triangles indicate where we have
introduced genomic quality control the
genomic quality control which I will
talk more about in a second is gene
expression profiling and whole genome
sequencing which we feel is important
because of we do not want to put any
dangerous mutations into
into sell into people if those cells are
to last for the rest of their lives
which is what our plans are
we make sure that the cells are
definitely neurons by the green triangle
they're the mature nods we confirm that
they are definitely neurons by
electrophysiology that is the electrical
activity of the cells which is typical
of dopamine neurons of that specific
type and also by making them release
neurotransmitter and making sure that
they make that they release dopamine and
not other neurotransmitters so
essentially that's an in vitro
functional test
our genomic Quality Control has is done
at four stages we as you see in that
circle reprogramming is the first stage
second stage is quality control of the
IPS cells number three is the expansion
of cells now I'll tell you in advance
this is the most dangerous part of the
entire process because this is the time
at which mutations occur in the
population the next stage is
differentiation and then at that stage
we want to make sure that the cells are
what we hope that they are that we can
do there we can understand their
identity and check one more time to see
whether they have any mutation this is
all done before the cells at transplant
at this stage we can we freeze the cells
down so we can do all these quality
controls before the transplantation the
cells to be to the people I'm just going
to go briefly through the methods that
we've developed for reprogramming the
chief concern about reprogramming was
that reprogramming cells might introduce
mutations we showed that that with this
paper which we publish in 2016 that it
is unlikely that reprogramming will
introduce any dangerous mutations you do
see introduction of variants for reasons
that you will see you later
but the important take-home lesson is
that reprogramming is benign it doesn't
introduce any cancer associated
mutations the only variants that we see
are ones that occur and are benign they
occur all the time in our own bodies and
they're benign this has been confirmed a
couple of times by other researchers now
the second stage is characterizing the
IPS cells to make sure that they are
pluripotent induced pluripotent stem
cells the way that people use to do this
about
seven years ago or so was to take cells
around a million cells injects them into
an immunocompromised Mouse this is
called the teratoma assay and it relied
on those cells around two months later
forming a tumor which you could then
take out and analyze when you do
histological analysis you can see that
cells from all three germ layers have
developed so there are typical things
like cartilage nerve cells and meet the
dermal derivative like muscle
we decided in the 2009 or so that there
was probably a better way of doing this
so we developed the pleura test
diagnostic test for pluripotency this
was developed by my colleague Franz
Josef Muller and another member of my
group this allows you to prove that the
cells are pluripotent without using the
teratoma assay and not using animals an
animal-free assay the way this works is
we've developed a website called
Claritas org this website currently has
800 registered user sites that is more
than one investigator each each
institution is registered we've had
20,000 data set uploads
he's a gene expression profile they is
now used in 29 countries and in fact we
have licensed thermo Fisher to do pleura
tests with their microarrays last year
so our main objective was to make this
so easy that people would not need any
bioinformatics expertise so it's an
algorithm which works on the on the
computer it was based on machine
learning so it is and it is quite
reliable the steps are to run a gene
expression by RNA sequencing or an array
you upload the raw data to the plur test
website and then what comes out is a
data analysis including a diagram that
resembles the one on the right if the
cells show up in that upper left-hand
corner that means that they are typical
of pluripotent cells and therefore
likely to be pluripotent themselves as I
show up anywhere else on this graph
they're probably differentiated or
abnormal in some other way
we have developed an RNA seek version of
Fleury test our first assay was based on
a luminous microarray but now we can
we've adapted it to RNA seek and we
published the first use of that in a
paper week in a collaboration with one
of our colleagues here in San Diego to
analyze 222 IPS cell line using RNA
sequencing and you can see the picture
from the figure from the paper on the
right which shows that most of the cell
lines but not all of them gather in that
upper left-hand quadrant is there
slightly off the main the dark region in
the red because RNA seek data give you
slightly different results and
microarray data which is not surprising
but they are in fact pluripotent by this
assay on the lower left you can see the
a little snapshot of the website and
over on the lower right you can see the
increase in RNA seek that is fast queue
files that have been uploaded to
Claritas org up to last month that is
now around 1600
it's also been recognized by an
international group called international
stem-cell nishan initiative iski we
published this work this year as a
collaborative effort to establish to
assess assess all these established
techniques to determine the
developmental and malignant potential of
human pluripotent stem cells and you'll
see that this is a diagram from a figure
in that paper showing that a new
potential pluripotent stem cell line can
go through first
Fleury test and then followed by other
assays to find out more about themselves
but the recommended test for initial
characterization is in fact Clarita
okay here's the issue I told you earlier
this is where a lot of things can go
wrong during the expansion of the cells
and we started noticing this quite a few
years ago as did others in this field we
found out that copy numbers of genes
would change during cell proliferation
of human pluripotent stem cells this
just shows you one example from that
paper and we use snip genotyping which
only looks that looks at takes a global
view of the entire genome at pretty high
resolution higher resolution than
karyotyping but lower resolution than
sequencing and you can see just at a
glance that in all the samples we looked
at there are many many duplications of
certain chromosomes including chromosome
12 from a zone 17 and the X chromosome
as well as some others so this is what
has been shown to occur in many many
dull lives now all over the world and so
I think that is the incentive to come up
with methods for checking the genomic
integrity of the cell this is one
example about how easy it is to do this
with live data typing this is a
comparison of two different passage
numbers this is also in that paper of
the of a embryonic stem cell line from
the University of Chicago you can see at
the early passage at the top of that
graph all those little dots running down
the middle mean that the B there's only
one copy of the gene if you look at
later passage you can see that that
single line has changed into two lines
that means there's an extra copy of the
of this particular region of the
chromosome this is a common duplication
that many people have now discovered on
chromosome 20 it occurs in pluripotent
stem cells very frequently
okay so we've also shown that there are
the mutations accumulate with expansion
the paper we published several years ago
and we first discovered that one of
those mutations was a deletion of p53 if
you culture the cells long enough it's
virtually inevitable that they will
acquire p53 mutations and the reason for
that is that p53 gives us cells a
advantage they are more resistant to die
in the culture and they probably divide
a bit quicker but if you just look at
the data every time a cell divides about
5 to 7 changes occur in the genome so as
I said earlier changes in the genome are
perfectly normal and we are in fact
mosaics we have lots of different
genomes in our body
most of those changes are benign because
the genome is a really big place and if
you just randomly mutate it you'll very
seldom hit something that is dangerous
but some of the changes drive cancer and
especially important that there is
accumulation of this mutation or loss of
p53 because p53 is a is a gene that is
mutated and about 50% of cancers
essentially if you lose p53 you lose the
signal to tell the cells to stop
dividing and it also makes itself as I
said earlier resistant to stress so p53
mutations provide a growth advantage in
pluripotent stem cells and therefore the
frequency of mutations employed for stem
cells increases with cell expansion the
figure at the bottom is from a paper
from Kevin Egan's lab in which he
obtained embryonic stem cell banked
embryonic stem cells from several
different sources no ESI
Children's Hospital Boston and why cell
and also the Sheffield Sheffield group
and he found that in many cases
obviously not all when these cells were
expanded when the passage number
increased from left to right the
proportion of cells that were were had
mutations in p53 increase and you can
see for the W a26 there the increase
appears to be exponential at the end
which is what you'd expect if these
cells are taking over
they also found mutations in the wa9
also known as h9 cell line which is very
popular its h9 was the cell line that we
used to show p53 mutations in the first
place and also used it widely for our
snip genotyping assays and it also
showed p53 mutations in this bank called
masterchef which is Sheffield University
okay the last stage differentiation of
the cell of course the a phase will be
cell type-specific in our case is
differentiation to dopamine neuron as I
said earlier we have developed a really
robust methods so that we can make
dopamine neurons every single type of
every single patient
these are little pictures of you know
sight of chemistry from five different
patients showing th positive and fox a
to positive dopamine neurons
what we we we thought again that one
shouldn't have to test for dopamine
neuron function if you have an assay
that will predict functionality of cells
or cultures of cells so early on we
obtained a group of samples from some of
our collaborators in the GeForce labs
from Jun Takahashi ler and Souter Mao
and Parmar and of course we have our own
cell lines and this is a principal
component analysis that we did early on
using micro arrays showing that the the
green cells which are dopamine neurons
at two different stages day 13 and day
25 the dopamine neurons that you can see
on the left from day 25 are yellow dots
cluster with Jun Takahashi's red dot and
the deuter's green dot the earlier stage
dopamine neuron precursor cells from our
lab day 13 today 16 the yellow dots
they're cluster with Mallen Parmar cells
those are she uses an earlier stage for
transplantation but looks like they're
on the same time courses ourselves and
also in this diagram you can see the
neural stem cells which are used by
international stem cell in a trophic
strategy for trying to rescue the
remaining dopamine neurons in patients
another kind of new neuron cortical
neurons undifferentiated IPS cells and
also the fetal mesencephalon which was
the tissue that was used to treat
Parkinson's patients in the 1980s and
90s
so now we're in the process developing a
flurry test like algorithm which we call
neuro test again it's gene expression
based and quality control si like Fleury
tests the cells are validated by
non-genomic criteria we use flow
neurotransmitter release and animal
studies like flurry test neuro test is
intended to replace the animal and the
in vitro assays a cell line equivalent
and if you see there's a heat map on the
left which just shows that we we
designate cells as passing or failing
other assets and then we do gene
expression on them and you'll see that
we have turned the pleura test algorithm
on its head so that the dopamine neurons
will turn up in the upper left hand
quadrant like the pluripotent cells did
in flurry test in the middle at the very
bottom right hand corner or the IPS
cells they came from and in the middle
there are different stages of
differentiating dopamine neurons on
their way to becoming day 25
transplantable cell
just wanted to show you that this is one
of the ways that we find out whether the
cells are functional or not this is the
hardest way this involves taking
dopamine out of an animal a rat in this
case this is an immune suppressed rat
and we've killed off all the dopamine
neurons at one side that's the upper
left-hand corner the upper right-hand
corner shows our transplants of human
cells and it's important to notice that
those dark staining cells there are the
human dopamine neurons and that they
stay right where we put them which is
very important the animals recover from
the loss of dopamine so those cells can
compensate for the loss of dopamine on
that side of the brain and if you look
up very closely you can see that these
cells that are in this very tight
configuration actually are sending axons
out throughout the striatum
as I mentioned earlier I just want to
bring this back to full circle and
remind you that using at all August
therapy allows for simple cell
manufacturing one six well plate will
give us 50 to 60 million dopamine
neurons that's plenty for our
transplantation of two to five million
cells and all of the QC that we need to
do in contrast for heart restoration
plans in progress they are requiring a
billion cardiac cells international stem
cell Inc which is using a neuro trophic
New York trophic approach to try to
rescue the remaining dopamine neurons
plans to transplant 70 million neural
stem cells into patients brain
so this allows us this lack of the
simple cell manufacturing allows us to
scale out rather than up we don't need
to produce millions of cells and so
we're testing a collaboration in a
collaboration with scale by labs in the
Bay Area in a project that is funded by
CERN California Institute for genetic
medicine we are testing reagents in
parallel using very small input low
number of cells and low reagents cost
this allows us to optimize the
differentiation conditions without
spending a ton of money with that I want
to acknowledge the people in my lab of
this project pretty in particular
Andris bratli all is directing it Roy
Williams is in charge of the
bioinformatics and the rest of the
people in lab all collaborate I also
have outside collaborators that are
listed on the right and I just want to
close by showing the my lab with another
one of our collaborators we are here we
are at the Wild Animal Park meeting with
our collaborators to try to rescue the
northern white rhino one of our
collaborators is that Rhino which you
can see behind us she's a southern white
rhino he's been brought in to serve as a
surrogate if we can produce embryos from
ICF cells that we've made into gametes
so thank you for your time I am finished